HEY, what is happening, whaddup, its ya boi...
PEWDIEPIE
Big announcement, big announcement, (clapping and exultancy) Let's get some excitement everyone,
Got a big announcement!
I'm going Family-Friendly now
So no more swearing.
No more sexual jokes.
And definitely not any hitler jokes, okay?
Nothing..
None of that!
*weird screams*
I wish I was joking.. I'm not.  *laughs*
It seems that youtube has made some changes about a third of my videos got de-monetized,
Gonna have to, uh, you know
Family-Friendly from now on, so I don't go homeless. Okay? I love money too much,
I love money too much, okay. No more swearing
Family-Friendly Felix as I like to call myself
Felix the family
Felix the family that's right from now on we're not calling it Bros. We're calling it
Familyyyyy! what's that? Did I make less money yesterday than I did in
2013? Rucka Rucka Ali did a really good song I can't show it because this video will get de-monetized
But link is in the description. I think you'll enjoy it. It's a legit
Good song would love to show it, but I caaaan't. Public service announcements, okay. They're made to protect
families.
public service announcements
They're made to make families happy and that's what we do on Family Friendly Felix channel. My family
how you doin? my family? handshake
Handshakes as we do in the.. pleased to meet.. we don't do Brofist anymore. We're doing handshakes.
So we're going to go through some public service announcements for family friendliness
To protect the family hopefully we can learn something and become more family friendly this one is from America
it's called don't put it in your mouth
*Laughs*
Family Friendly *sarcastic claps*, it's Family Friendly
It's seriously bad, okay. Let's say let's see what it says
Why do you think your mommy or daddy are always telling you don't put that in your mouth? cuz you're a wh**e damn it!!
God no
Family Friendly Felix.. okay here. We go.
Hi kids
Why are we on television anyway?
Why do you look like you're about to murder me? Both of you, if I saw you two in an alleyway
I would.. I would scream
I would scream and I would run for my life.. to tell a little story about why you shouldn't put things into your mouth when
You don't know what they are
the lip syncing is
Impeccable.. about why you shouldn't put things into your mouth *ma name is Jeff*
and why you should never take anything a stranger tries to give you
Why Not ? *Stupidly*
Never listen to anyone that doesn't blink. Rule number one for Family-Friendly Felix tips
if you don't blink, if they don't blink (he said bling, no?)
You're going to have a problem all right?
Have you ever made anyone that talks to you like this you may want to run run and hide call aahh *Eyes Dries Out*?
It's somebody else's medicine some bad food or some poison you could get very sick.
*Alienatic Expression* I don't wanna be sick ..
kids want to get sick okay when I was a kid. I wanted to get sick [alright]
If my sister was was sick. I would go to her room play video games in there. I'm sick
I get sick from her and then I get [to] stay home in school from school and play video games
You can't say I don't want to get sick and thinks kids will understand ok I love you
Can I eat the guitar? No!
My God *Face Palms* oh my God *Head Ache Expression*
This is worse than I thought okay well
*Disappointed In Humanity* *Thinking of Non Curse Word*
She's clearly not paying attention, but you can help me sing a song about eating things that don't belong inside you. Okay.
I wasn't really hungry anyway. Oh, wait. Maybe a little bit. Okay everybody
So cringy, it's just so cringy. If you see something that you want to eat, before you do anything
Remember this song: Don't you put it in your mouth. Don't you put it in your mouth.*Spits Piss* Don't you stuff it in your face.
Don't stuff it in your face.
Tho it might look good to eat.
And it might look good to taste
And it might look good to taste *Stupidly Repeating*
*CHORUS* You could get sick
*Pewd Laughs* Yukk *Tongues Out*
Real Quick
Yukk
Real Sick
Real ....... *Forgets Lyrics*
Don't you put it in your mouth
Aen Ae
Tell That to Someone you love
*Felix and  Puppet with Same Face*
Thats Right ! *Felix Talks Over (Okay)*
if its okay to eat.
if its okay to eat *Felix Expresses his Feeling*
like a muffin or a beet,
like a muffin or a beet ... *Interrupts* I know I was not supposed to eat it
Remember Boys and girls... oh my God. There's more of them
*CHORUS* Don't put it in your mouth.
Hey, what am I doing? I don't even like beets  then don't put it in your mouth. Bye
Bye, everyone remember what you telling me not to eat healthy stuff now
You're not supposed to eat beetroots
They're good for you.*Makes Urine Red* They're good for what what is that thing?
What is that?
Boys and girls never take anything from a stranger and don't put things in your mouth when you don't know what they are or listen
to crack cocaine addict [lions] I
*Aee eeaaahhhe*
Always ask someone you love before you put anything in your mouth. Hey, Satan should I?
*Laughs*
What my God?
Half of people who try cigarettes in college still smoke four years later
What's up guys? Hey, come on the cig?
You're a smoker? No, I never even bought my own pack
It's a trap
My God, why why does this exist? Why would you do that? Why would you do that?
Why why would you do that?
no, I
Never even bought my own pack dude
I I gotta save I mean those are some d*ck sucking lips like Jesus Christ
I can't make that joke sorry those are some lovemaking lips those are some lovemaking lips. I got hailie
It's a trap
I only smoke on Saturday. So doesn't even count
No, why did you say yes to this? No
You're better than that
I'm not a smoker smoker. I'm gonna do yoga tomorrow
I didn't it didn't it doesn't stop. It keeps [Processing] keeps going, the memes are
This is cringier than my content I and that's a first
It tastes like tropical kumquat so can't be bad for me
Unicorn Ryan no NO
Now I just feel like smoking, okay? I don't even smoke and I just definitely oh
Ok let's move on before. I said everyone start smoking okay. It's the only way to do it. Oh God. It's one about trains
Someones gonna die
Why is he so happy? now pinback here? He is and listen because I'm going to tell you a story okay all about the railways
Did you know every single day,
over 18,000 trains use our Railway system. amazing isn't it?
No, I am amazed. I do a great deal of rushing around the country from place to place
And [I] can't think of a nicer more comfortable way of doing that than in a really good train.
*Sucks in air*
Yeah, the hell was that
What the hell is that? What is that?
This guy is in love with trains. I think. My story really is about something else
I knew it your love for trains or rather someone else a lad called robbie (Who robs People). Oh my God a lad call Robbie
It legit looks like me when I was a kid
Equally stupid as well. Robbie, I already hate you like at this point
I just want Robbie to get hit by train to be honest
What's happening?
What is going on?
That scream!
What what is happening? They asked me to bring these back. Oh he won't be wearing those oh
No its to sad. Oh my God what the hell?
Robbie still keeps his boots. Nobody knows why not even robbie
After all they'll never be any use
Robbie bless him. Chances are he'll spend the rest of his life
in his wheelchair. oh my God. Oh my God, okay? Well. I mean, it's a good message. I understand it's a problem
There's so many railroads and people aren't careful and trains come a lot quicker than you think
And you don't really hear them as well, so I understand the danger, but just like was this the best way to tell it?
I don't know
I just love that scream so much
*scream*
It's the best scream I ever heard
Done in a really good train
*scream*
Oh my God. He's Gonna get electrified
Pass me that piece of wood
oh dude he's good
He's gonna get electrified. Dude don't go up there! You gottta ahm ah..
ah, No!
Jimmy!
Not Jimmy.
Why is [it] funny? It's not fun. There's nothing funny about it, but it's also hilarious
Timmy,Timmy! Well you shouldn't have told him to get the frisbee
Family-Friendly Felix well
Big announcement, big announcement, (clapping and exultancy)! Let's get some excitement everyone. Got a big announcement!
PEWDIEPIE